une église de saint lambert vous voyez
des images est en danger en piètre état
en fait l'édifice avons figuré sur la
liste des édifices du patrimoine local
il a été donc l'édifice laisser
complètement à l'abandon
une histoire qui rappelle bien sûr n'est
celle de la fameuse maison redpath sur
sherbrooke ouest qui a été finalement
démoli
émilie dubreuil nous raconte
lamentable
iriez de fait comme entretien sur sept
ce bâtiment qui appartient à la ville
c'est scandaleux
il ya urgence à le protéger à
l'entretenir elle alors et novaes avant
qu'il tombe en ruine et avant que le feu
prenne aussi éventuellement fin 19ème
siècle sur la rive sud de montréal
la construction du pont victoria en 1852
va transformer ce monde agricole en
milieu urbain que la compagnie du grand
tronc à qui appartient le pont voit d'un
oeil favorable cette colonisation
il va faire un cadeau aux gens de saint
lambert qui ne s'appelle pas encore
saint lambert un terrain pour construire
un lieu de culte anglicans puisque les
habitants ici sont à l'époque en grande
majorité anglophone
les anglais car à jouer une majeure rôle
dans le développement des salles en
berne y est on a besoin de respecter ça
et on a besoin de respecter la passé
parce que sans passer par de futurs
or ce vestige du passé au coeur même de
la ville de saint-lambert est malmené le
temple anglicans devenue une loge
maçonnique en 1929 est racheté par la
ville en 1998 est complètement laissée à
l'abandon et ce sont de simples citoyens
qui veille au grain je téléphonais la
semaine dernière pour on protège ce côté
ici et heureusement là j'ai été entendu
mais je trouve ça incroyable ce soit les
citoyens qui doivent ferme vers une
demande aux employés municipaux pour
protéger des vitraux qui à mon avis ont
beaucoup de valeur
certains citoyens sont d'autant plus
révolté par l'inaction de la ville que
c'est la municipalité elle-même qui a
fait classer l'édifice patrimoine local
on a une responsabilité quand on achète
un bâtiment et on le sait et on doit
selon la réglementation le l'entretenir
or à saint-lambert même certains
conseillers municipaux se demande si la
direction de la ville ne fait pas exprès
pour précipiter la chute du temple on a
l'impression qu'il est sabotée de
l'intérieur comme sont arrachés des
planches volontairement
il faut dire que le conseil de ville est
fortement divisés sur la question
certains voudraient se débarrasser du
temps passionné il y en a d'autres comme
moi qui veulent absolument donner une
nouvelle vocation à l'édifice au coeur
du centre-ville
je comprends pas l'indifférence des gens
qui considèrent que c'est une vieille
affaire a jeté par terre
les amants du patrimoine vont donc
continuer de se battre
déjà un petit miracle s'est produit
quelques jours après que nous ayons fait
ces entrevues des employés municipaux
sont venus poser des scellés sur le toit